[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing harry potter
the chamber of secrets blue powder and
diagon alley
more specifically we're going to be
discussing how and
why harry ended up in nocturne alley
the first time that he used the flu
network this video was heavily requested
on my video the other day
where i asked you all to comment video
requests so i hope it's to your liking
for those unaware the flu network is a
network of interconnected fireplaces
that connect the wizarding world in
order to utilize the flu network
you also need flu pounder a pound of
thrown into the fireplace
that turns the flames into harmless
emerald green flames
in the chamber of secrets when harry
leaves the burrow to go to diagon alley
he uses the flu network for the first
time
diagonally he coughed but what's more
interesting about this
is that harry doesn't end up in diagon
alley at all
he ends up in a much more nefarious
nocturn alley
full of all sorts of dark arts shops so
how did harry end up there well the
first thing worth mentioning
is that harry didn't pronounce diagon
alley exactly right
it was his first time using the flu
network and he was nervous
understandably harry's first time using
the flu network also happened to be at
the weasleys
and so he was overloaded with all sorts
of different advice
from each of the weasley family members
well alright
you go after arthur said mrs weasley now
when you get into the fire
say where you're going and keep your
elbows tucked in ron advised
and your eyes shut said mrs weasley the
soot don't fidget
said ron or you might well fall out of
the wrong fireplace
but don't panic and get out too early
wait until you see fred and george
trying hard about all this in mind harry
took a pinch of flu powder
and walked to the edge of the fire he
took a deep breath scattered the powder
into the flames
and stepped forward the fire felt like a
warm breeze
he opened his mouth and immediately
swallowed a lot of hot ash
diagonally he coughed an old wooden
street sign hanging over a shop
selling poisonous candles told him he
was in nocturnally
this didn't help as harry had never
heard of such a place
he supposed he hadn't spoken clearly
enough through his mouth full of ashes
back in the weasley's fire trying to
stay calm he wondered what to do
so how did harry mess up his brief stint
with the flu network
so badly nocturne alley sounds nothing
like diagonally
what it boils down to is his
pronunciation you see
harry almost said diagon alley and the
result is that he
almost made it to diagonally but not
quite
as he slightly mispronounced the name he
ended up in the adjacent
nocturne alley and that's it for this
video if you enjoyed the content please
like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time remember
happiness can be found even in the
darkest of times
if only one remembers to turn on the
[Music]
light